[Music]
welcome back
now i've never personally met someone
who's been scammed online
by nigerian fraudsters but joe biden has
and he's actually naming her to his
cabinet
rick leventhal is in los angeles with
the story rick
and trey some critics are surprised by
president biden's choice to run the
federal unemployment program since
during susie levine's tenure at the head
of washington state's unemployment
security
department it's been rocked by scandal
including a huge scam
by nigerian criminals costing the state
over 600 million dollars in fraudulent
claims
foxnews.com reports levine and her
husband eric gave 400 thousand dollars
to the biden campaign
and other democratic causes over the
past two years
and now she's reportedly been tapped to
run the federal office that helps
process
unemployment claims a recent washington
state
audit faulted the department levine was
running for failing to fix a software
issue that contributed to last spring's
massive
unemployment payout debacle a total of
more than 122 thousand fraudulent claims
using identity stolen and earlier data
breaches leading to more than
600 million in undeserved payments
although the state has now recovered
357 million dollars of that money
washington state's auditor blamed a
third party for another data breach
exposing private information of 1.6
million residents filing for
unemployment last year
and rebuked levine for delays in
supplying auditors information about the
fraud
but levine told the seattle times the
system has now been repaired saying
we do have definitive proof that the
countermeasures we have put in place
are working we have successfully
prevented hundreds of millions of
additional dollars
from going out to these criminals and
prevented thousands of fraudulent claims
from being filed
levine's new title would be interim
assistant secretary
getting the job permanently will require
senate confirmation which could be tough
for trey
because of questions about her
performance in washington state
trey thank you rick